une image qui se retrouve dans tous les
médias aujourd'hui le président
américain donald trump qui est apparu
pour la première fois publiquement avec
un masque c'est devenu aux états unis
vraiment un objet de débat politique
passionné le masque avec la flambée de
qovu 19 on parle de 66 mille nouveaux
cas 24 heures c'est un nouveau record
avec moi valérie beaudouin spécialiste
de la politique américaine bonjour
valérie un bon jour là comment expliquer
ce revirement de situation donald trump
a toujours évité se présenter en public
avec un masque et vous venez et bien le
prize-pool bien le préciser en public
parce qu'on le sait qu'il a porté un
masque dans certaines visites du sinn
par exemple mais lorsqu'il était devant
les médias il refusait de se présenter
avec le masque leur indiquer les mêmes
jo bail d'une pour emporter
alors pourquoi ce changement parce que
l'oeil ça paraît ainsi qu'il voulait se
faire photographier pour envoyer un
message
est ce que c'est les sondages que voit
monsieur thiam qu'ils constatent hédi
ben écoutez il faut envoyer un message
parce que clairement ma gestion de la
pandémie ne plaît pas tous les
américains et un sondage de nbc qui est
sorti vendredi entre autres qui dit 67%
des américains ne sont pas satisfaits de
sa gestion de la crise
il y aussi le fait et vous l'avez dit on
a des records combat en ce moment pour
la crise lakovic 19 qui est pas du tout
régler d'un sud des états unis
et on n'est même pas à cette fameuse
deuxième vague on est toujours cette
première vague alors peut-être que c'est
en réaction tout ça est ce que ça peut
être aussi le forme d'admission de sa
part et là souvent minimisé la coved 19
une forme d'admission dans ce sens que
il admet qu'il faut maintenant
intensifier les actions contre lacko
vide
écoutez selon bon il baisse qu'ils
veulent l'admettre publiquement je crois
que non mais vous avez raison peut-être
qu'on l'admette cette façon là parce
qu'il a vu dans un très très court très
courte intervention avec les
journalistes avant de se rendre dans cet
hôpital militaire où elle voit à porter
le masque
le jay jamais été contre le masque vous
choisir le bon moment pour le porter et
l'ess qui la dirige s'est justifié en
disant écoutez je suis avec des
militaires qui sont malades certains
viennent d'être opérée alors il est
toujours une justification derrière le
port du masque peut-être pont pour
justement perdre la face en dix ans
pendant des mois qui ont refusé
d'apporter da alors il se justifie dans
ces deux quartiers qui vont être
contents oui s'il se parlent encore les
deux
c'est ça je lisais dans washington post
que ça fait des semaines que se sont pas
parlés ouais exactement on le fait en
docteur farocki c'est la voix un peu
dissidente de cette unité de lutte à la
cuvée 2009 on le voit de moins en moins
en public qui donne des entrevues à des
médias et sylla et souvent il va
contredire le message non seulement du
président john mais aussi de mike pence
le vice président qui est à la tête de
cette lutte à la pandémie
c'est peut-être une façon aussi de
porter le masque de vouloir détourner
l'attention après tout la controverse
autour de rodgers tourner son ancien
conseiller dont il a commué la peine
dans l'est dans les dernières heures et
les réactions continuent écouter de
sortir robert tout le monde est alors
celui qui est à la tête à la tête de
cette enquête sur l'ingérence en hausse
dans l'élection 2016 or dans une rare
fois ait décidé de prendre la parole ça
s'est fait dans une lettre où washington
post en faisant écouter au rajasthan est
un criminel c'est la dernière personne
qui a été arrêté je voudrais demander
une enquête qui découlent de toute cette
histoire d'ingérence ruse alors il dit
c'est un criminel et c'est pour ça qu'il
méritait d'être derrière les barreaux
par ce poncif cette semaine et devait
commencer à purger une peine de 40 mois
de prison et son ami est conséquent ses
collègues dressent je vois ça comme ça
le président américain a décidé de
commuer sa peine et c'est pas tout son
entourage qui semble être d'accord avec
cette décision là parce que c'est une
décision personnelle
il n'y a pas une raison derrière lui il
dit que c'est univoque la raison qui
avait une chasse aux sorcières et toute
cette enquête russe était bidon mais
quand même là il utilise son pouvoir
exécutif pour vraiment aider un ami qui
ne l'a pas très belle seconde qui avait
été reconnu coupable d'avoir menti
d'avoir intimidé des témoins pour
protéger donald trump dans l' enquête
sur les gérances russe pendant la
campagne présidentielle
la dernière campagne c'est un peu c'est
un peu tordu c'est un peu spécial que ce
soit donald trump qui puisse lui même
annulé sa peine
ouais on le voit comme une récompense
pour sa fidélité envers le président
américain n'a pas été l'école de tous
les anciens collaborateurs et un petit
pelosi qui a dit qu'on devrait passer
une loi au congrès pour limiter les
pouvoirs de n'importe quel président
pour ne pas pouvoir gracié commuée des
peines de gens qui ont un dossier qui
les concernent directement
c'est un abus de pouvoir vraiment de
faire ça alors on veut passer de loi
pour qu'à l'avenir changer ça mais quand
même la cour suprême que confirmer lé
pouvoir du président du pardon
finalement présidentielle alors ça
risque d'être difficile à faire en
terminant valérie savait toute une
semaine pour donald trump a sa propre
nièce qui va rajouter une couche avec
son livre qui sort cette semaine
est ce que c'est la première fois qu'un
membre de la famille jam sort un ouvrage
avec des révélations et qui s'annonce
explosive sur le président alors il est
membre de la famille qui ont déjà parlé
aux médias mais une ouvrages comme celui
ci de quelqu'un je voudrais aussi créé
des passes une docteure en psychologie à
l'arrivée va vraiment dans l'analyse de
son oncle d'aventuré et on est potes
comme un livre que de john bolton par
les coulisses de la présidence mais
vraiment pourquoi dans notre chanter
comme ça pourquoi est on parle de cette
famille dysfonctionnelle qui ont mené à
la création de ce personnage et ce
qu'elle dit dans ce livre selon les
extraits qui sont sortis c'est que
finalement si donnant une part le
deuxième mandat ça peut être la fin de
la démocratie américaine rien de moins
et que c'est un être narcissique selon
son éveil que son évaluation de docteur
en psychologie on tente encore de
bloquer cette parution du livre un autre
livre contente de bloquer devant les
tribunaux mais ça devrait paraître mardi
on a d'ailleurs devancé la date
peut-être pour éviter d'être bloqué
justement donc mardi version en anglais
et je crois qu'en france s est prévue
pour le mois d'octobre qui sont bien
ouais ça arrive toujours un peu plus
tard mais pour les gens qui vont être
disponible cette semaine on a eu john
bolton ya pas très longtemps son ancien
conseiller de sécurité nationale et
maintenant c'est sa nièce qui sont pas
faire dans la dentelle en parlant de son
donc le type d'appareil qui va paraître
oui on va certainement merci beaucoup
valérie merci au revoir au revoir